Let's add these
two mixed numbers.
2 and 5/13 plus 7 and 6/13.
And the way I like to
think about in my head,
I like to separate out the mixed
numbers into the whole number
component and the
fractional component.
So we can rewrite 2 and
5/13 as 2 plus 5 over 13.
And then we can write that plus.
And then 7 and 6/13, we can
rewrite as plus 7 plus 6/13.
So all I did is I rewrote this.
And I essentially
expanded it out.
I broke up the mixed numbers
into their whole number
parts and their
fractional parts.
And then what I
like to do is I like
to add the whole number parts.
So this 2 plus this
7, so I'll do that.
So I'll do the 2
plus 7 over here.
I'll add those up.
And to that, I will add
the fractional parts.
So to that, I will add
the 5/13 to the 6/13.
So if we add the whole
number parts, 2 plus 7 is 9,
and the fractional
parts, they already
have the same denominator
in this problem.
5/13 plus 6/13,
same denominator.
You're going to get 11/13.
5 plus 6 is 11.
So you get 9 plus 11/13.
Well, that's just the
same thing as 9 and 11/13.
And we are done.